bonjour que si envoûtant bonjour vous
êtes le directeur de la sacem à la
société des auteurs compositeurs et
éditeurs de musique la saison
touristique commencera dans un mois et
demi à peu près une saison touristique
qui ne profitent pas assez selon vous
que ces routes en aux artistes de notre
pays
mais écoutez je ne sais que je crois
qu'ils étaient importants si vous voulez
je vais commencer un petit peu en vous
raconter une anecdote gts cette année 1
dans un établissement pendant les
vacances je voyais la ferveur des
musiciens parce que là je veux saluer
tous les musiciens qui ont des oursins
de formation musicale ont animé des
vacances parce que c'est un pur parce
que le live est revenue 13 musiciens 14
musiciens sur scène et en fait je me
disais mais qu'est l'art de quelle
détermination quel investissement qui
n'est peut-être pas suffisamment
reconnus alors c'est vrai que dans la
démarche je me dis pourquoi ne pas
alimenter aussi le secteur touristique
entre autres bien sûr de la musique de
manière plus intelligente de manière
plus efficace plus innovantes
vous voyez quand il ya une production
qui a quand même son volume dans le pays
il faut que ça alimente notre économie
voilà donc mais je n'ai pas
particulièrement secteur touristique
mais c'est vrai que c'est un secteur de
développement il ce secteur dans
lesquelles beaucoup de pays ont montré
que la culture et le tourisme doit mal
en synergie vous avez bien fait de dire
que pendant les vacances il ya eu
beaucoup de formations qui se produisait
on a parlé des papilles ceux qui font de
la résistance ce qui sont quatre à
génère la perfecta même s'il y en a
plein il y en a plein
pourquoi il ne joue que pendant les
vacances mes côtés je ne peux pas vous
répondre ce que je peux vous dire si
vous voulez c'est que nous en tant
qu'organisme de droits d'auteur nous
essayons de d'avoir une pensée d'avant
garde sur l'innovation sous comment
alimenter le développement grâce à la
création intellectuelle la création
musicale
donc encore une fois je vous dis que je
pense que nous avons déjà sollicité
l'association des maires de martinique
nous avons déjà sollicité des médias
nous avons essayé de travailler que les
dits choqués de la ronde réunit les
chefs d'orchestre tout ça dans une
optique civile et de favoriser la
distribution optimale bien sûr aussi à
les fédérer pour ça qu'ils soient dûment
aussi qu'il parle d'une main
voix est restée force de proposition et
comptablement alors particulièrement
puisque vous en parlez le secteur du
tourisme est l'un des secteurs où
effectivement nous pouvons nous
interroger sur comment mieux alimenter
le secteur du tourisme avec l'art la
musique question exemple très rapidement
pourquoi on pourra pas mettre des écrans
dans les hôtels par exemple avec les
balais avec les artistes pour qu'on peut
pas faire des sets 2-6 7-6 6-2 c'est
très timide mais cette liste voilà donc
si vous voulez nous essayons de colas
bruit avec tout le monde donc dont le
cmt dont et les organismes les plus
divers pour essayer d'approfondir les
idées qui nous permettront d'alimenter
encore ces départs naturels cette
démarche nous avait on est tous allés à
saint domingue on a vu comment ces
domaines s'organise pour que la batterie
apple bat le bachata et le merengue qui
sont leurs deux sources musicales
alimente le tourisme et moi j'ai vécu
des expériences extraordinaires à
trinité c'est la même chose ainsi
absolument le concept culture et
tourisme est en concert aujourd'hui qui
est très moderne et que nous devons
partager alors la culture ce n'est pas
seulement la musique c'est aussi la
danse par exemple et sean bailey on
pourrait développer le gym baylet dans
le tourisme entre hop on pourrait
développer le jazz crurent dans le
tourisme en fait ya beaucoup de choses à
faire et puis le zouk pourquoi pas à sa
demande des moniteurs ça demande une
philosophie ça demande aussi que dans
l'argumentaire attractif nous ayons 6 à
la demande aussi convergentes et au
corps du zouk aujourd'hui absolument
donc s'ils voient les français pour
tenter de personnes marché national ça
sent bon le redémarrage s'il faut
pourquoi pas parce qu'on aille jusqu'au
bout
on va vous demander de définir ce que
c'est que la production locale
culturelles artistiques monsieur
l'attention qu'il faut peut-être
comprendre c'est que mon moule la sacem
comme une fois nous sommes très neutre
et nous sommes dans une démarche de deux
de défense des droits mais aussi de
propositions en métropole nous
participons régulièrement au sein des
ministères de la culture à des
discussions sur la chanson française sur
les quotas vous voyez donc ils
arriveront alors bien évidemment au
niveau régional nous déclinons ces mêmes
priori aux préoccupations faire en sorte
que nous soyons dans une démarche
d'optimisation de la production de
musique alors la production la
production locale haut var et ce dans le
secteur musical
cette production d'aucun comment vous la
définiriez cie maurice via le ton se met
à chanter mike brant ce producteur local
écoutez chaque pays a ses traditions
musicales
on peut identifier les rythmes
traditionnels de la martinique on peut
identifier la production musicale manque
nicaise à travers bon à la fois la
tradition disons ural baylet kalenda
chouval bwa mais aussi à travers les
cadences perfecta ses lecteurs fait tout
ce qu'ils nient pas mais qui est avec
notre studio fait du dancehall
mais cette richesse qui violent jamais
écrivait déjà la production musicale
menthe c'est tout ce qui est
produit avec des capitaux par des
martiniquais et bien évidemment ça
n'empêche pas que monsieur x de monsieur
jack veut le faire indique le ring eh
ouais c'est pas que la valeur nous ont
valu conseillé de le chanter en créole
oui pourquoi pas ce que c'est ça c'est
ça l'identité ont valu conseillé aussi
voyez c'est d'avoir une démarche
identitaire mais chacun est libre de
recel travail d'organisation auprès des
artistes aussi pour qu'ils puissent
définir quelque chose qui serait
purement martin qu'est 100% marque et
puis à réussir à faire par exemple
sculpteur ça sera aux côtés de danseurs
à côté de nos deux musiciens et puis
arrivé avec une offre ses volcans vous
savez que il ya des démarches
expérimentales dont ont pu s'inspirer
depuis très longtemps la réunion a crié
un pôle régional des musiques actuelles
c'est-à-dire une instance qui est
financé par la région réunion et qui a
pour objectif un de mémoriser de fédérer
3 d'exporter donc voilà des choses qui
sont très simples
la guadeloupe a créé un pôle régional
des arts du spectacle vous voyez bon
nous n'avons pas l'équivalent ici donc
c'est un souhait que nous pouvons
partager et d'ailleurs je suis membre du
kop du cce comité culture et du cash et
environnement nous allons essayer
effectivement faire des propositions
dans le cadre des orientations
budgétaires acquis mais à la
collectivité territoriale puisque nous
sommes un autre service santé
avec cette nouvelle équipe qu'il est ce
que vous sentez une envie de faire
quelque chose qui irait dans le sens ce
qui se passe à saint denis roux apprête
à pitre écoutez pourquoi pas oui bien
sûr mais je crois que tout élu a une
responsabilité quelle que soit son bord
je pense que les élus qui sont
aujourd'hui à l'accepter ont l'ambition
de développer la martinique
ça me semble évident alors bon nous
notre ambition c'est de contribuer quel
que soit le bord c'est de contribuer
avec eux
à identifier les problématiques à créer
les conditions si vous êtes dans le
développement à créer les conditions
d'étude de dunes de voyez c'est ça notre
notoriété à sion il n'y a pas que les
artistes qui doivent s'organiser
il n'y a pas que les collectivités
politique décisionnel qui doivent
forcément prendre des six une question
d'éducation
si un jeune aujourd'hui n'écoute que
ryan a n'écoute que beyoncé n'écoute que
ceux ci qu'est-ce qu'on peut faire il
faut éduquer le peuple ça passe par
exemple de partenariat avec verizon a dû
cesser tout à l'heure nous revenons de
guadeloupe 1 au sein d'une dune d'une
manifestation un coup blanc qui
s'appelle au coeur les antilles et les
régions françaises comme est au coeur de
l'économie mondiale des cultures et des
savoirs ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'il ya une réflexion
aujourd'hui on parle d'économie de
culture l'économie de la connaissance
l'économie du savoir
nous avons identifié effectivement que
il y a des éléments très identitaire ici
très particulier dans la gastronomie
dans la peinture de la musique dans la
mode dans le théâtre dans l'audiovisuel
donc il faut absolument que nous
puissions prendre conscience de la
nécessité pour ses productions
d'alimenter notre développement et il
faut laisser une fois qu'on a pris c'est
que on était conscientiser autour de ce
lac est ce qu'on en fait et bien entre
elles explique qu au crès début et je
reviens cette question est-ce que vous
entrez par exemple dans le monde
éducatif
incontestablement dans les milieux
scolaires et contestable allemand c'est
important absolument d'ailleurs au sein
d'une association d'avant vous savez
nous n'avons nous avions créé une
association qui s'appelle impact avant
initiative manifeste pour la promotion
de la culture et du tourisme dans le cul
dans le tourisme mais à côté de ça nous
avons effectivement des préoccupations
au niveau de l'éducation nationale
pourquoi ne pas y trouver des politiques
innovantes dans le moment n'aurait pensé
maîtrise des télévisions dans les
autobus pour favoriser la connaissance
avec des programmes voyez avec des
contenus pédagogiques qui sont ancrées
dans l'histoire de la martinique
donc effectivement il faut voir définir
tout cadrage dans cette mondialisation
pour faire en sorte que la culture
puisse alimenter l'éducation le
développement qu'est ce que le milieu
politique
est-ce que la sacem est ce que les
artistes martiniquais
peuvent monte au rectorat de terville
dire madame la rectrice
voilà ce que nous voulons pour nos
enfants aujourd'hui c'est un autre débat
alors vous savez il y a eu un certain
nombre d'initiatives depuis locaux
musicale pour pouvoir travailler pour
faire en sorte de fédérer des artistes
mais on sait que c'est pas simple aussi
parce que la profession artistique tant
musicales et hétérogène il y adeux ceux
qui sont amateurs il ya ceux qui sont
professionnels il ya des profiteurs qui
fonctionne et d'autres qui ne fonctionne
pas voyez mais en tout cas je pense que
mes mondiaux sein de la drac il y à des
initiatives pour pouvoir intégrer les
artistes dans les écoles de plus en plus
l'an dernier nous avons fait aussi nu
une opération qui s'appelle la fabrica
chansons de manière mutualisée avec
l'adac l'éducation nationale la région
la sas et métaux et nous avons aussi des
résultats donc je pense que ce sont un
certain nombre d'initiatives et puis il
y a aussi un certain nombre
d'enseignants qui s'investissent dans
l'ain dans la conservation du patrimoine
en l'école de dillon il ya quand même
pas mal de choses qui se font depuis
surtout surtout qu'ils sont contents les
martiniquais eux mêmes ceux qui
aujourd'hui sont en âge d'avoir des
enfants qui éduquent leurs enfants
vous n'avez peut-être leur dire qu'il ya
une culture martiniquaise ou b oui il ya
une culture martiniquaise effectivement
à transmettre parce que c'est un secret
si vous voulez ce socle il est il est
dans la langue il est dans les
traditions musicales y lit dans dans la
gastronomie voyez bon mais c'est vrai
qu'on est confronté mais vous sentez
vous sentez cette montée du nationalisme
culturel martinique mais je sais pas
s'il faut parler de nationalisme
culturel parce que s'ils voulaient ce
sont des termes parfois qu'ils peuvent
eux être ambigu mais je pense qu'il ya
la question d'enracinement je préfère
parler de 7,7 notions d'enracinement et
compugen mona 10 aces et les on dit dans
coco qu'à aller vers l'universel
on sent que c'est un homme passionné
merci christian boutant dans le rythme
des artistes seront mieux exposés
pendant la saison touristique merci
d'avoir été avec une bonne journée dans
son planning